and I'm joined Now by mosab Hassan yusf
mosab great to see you um it's an
extraordinary story yours uh you were
the eldest son of a man who was one of
the co-founders of Hamas and indeed for
your early formative years you worked
alongside your your father so you got a
great insight into Hamas tell me this
from the start what were the intended
plans for Hamas when it was founded when
it started when it developed what was
the plan you know since its
establishment uh
Hamas has one goal in mind which is
annihilating the state of Israel like
the best let's say compromise that they
could do is having a truce for 15 years
a ceas fire for 15 years as maximum you
know but with no guarantee how they will
act after it's absurd
ER it's not a secret that Hamas wants to
destroy the state of Israel they cannot
accept Israel or accept uh Israel's
right to exist what was the point uh
that you decided to get out of there to
to flee this world this environment
you've been brought up in you know I I
have I have many reasons since I was a
child I asked my father many questions
about Hamas delusions about their
brutality about their abuse of power and
always he justified you know their
position then I was imprisoned with
Hamas I spent about 27 months in Israeli
prisons where Hamas was torturing their
own members our own people within
Israeli prisons they killed actually and
tortured hundreds of
prisoners uh and this is when I start
asking myself the question what if Hamas
become the ruler at some point what will
they do to our people and
uh many years later Hamas became the
ruler of Gaza and I wasn't surprised by
their brutality when you heard what
happened on October the 7th what was
your feeling about that look as I told
you I'm not surprised by Hamas brutality
but I was surprised by the scale of
their attack you know not to this degree
wiping out entire communities you know
messing with the nuclear power the most
powerful country in the region a country
with a uh trauma great Trauma from the
past with a A Memory of a holocaust and
uh all the Nazis did in the past Century
you they opened uh the Gates of Hell on
the Palestinian people this is how
irresponsible this group people are you
know that they are willing to actually
sacrifice many Palestinian children
the entire Palestinian people and use
them as a fuel to just achieve their
ideological agendas their religious
agendas they are careless they don't
care for the human life we have to
separate between what so-called
Palestinian cause and Hamas cause Hamas
cause is a sick one it's coming from the
pit of Hell you know and they need to be
removed uh from Power this is my message
as an ex Hamas member as a son of one of
Hamas Founders that enough of this if we
don't stop them now the next war is
going to be deadlier and only God knows
what will happen next if Hamas is not
finished as soon as possible M how many
regular Palestinians particularly in
Gaza do you think sympathize with Hamas
or indeed fully support them yeah you
know once Hamas is removed from Power
we're going to witness people
celebrating in Gaza I guarantee you that
the people of Gaza are oppressed for so
long and they had to endure Siege they
had to endure violence many
wars uh uh for the sake of Hamas uh uh
lust for power and for Hamas political
ambition when this comes to an end I
promise you
that the Palestinian people first of all
will thank Israel for what they did
second the uh idea of Anala the Jews and
the state of Israel will be dropped
forever you know because Hamas is the
you can say the last
experiment uh of adapting violence
trying to annihilate and destroy the
state of Israel this didn't work for
yasat it took him 40 years to realize
this and Hamas has been trying for 35
years to destroy Israel finally I hope
that they will come to this
understanding that Israel is going
nowhere if they insist on annihilating
Israel and of course if Iran keeps on
insisting on this goal this means the
destruction of the entire region this is
the only uncertain outcome of this
because Israel is going nowhere how do
we get to peace from here you know this
time I'm afraid that war is the only way
to
peace uh because if Hamas is not removed
from Power uh then they will uh build
more military they will build uh longer
uh range missiles and the next attack
the next war is going to be deadlier the
use of force is the last resort you can
find this in every
culture and
unfortunately now Hamas left Israel and
the Free World as well with no
choice uh but to fight them and put an
end for their
violence uh many civilians are dying I
understand this their blood is on the
hands of Hamas and Hamas only you see
it's interesting you say that because a
lot of pro Palestinians who I've had on
the show in the last two weeks don't
accept that argument they say that blood
of the civilians in Gaza is exclusively
on the hands of Israel and that Israel's
waged a repressive occupation for many
decades um there's been a prison camp
for gazans for a long long time and that
that has created the environment through
which a terror group like Hamas can
Thrive and indeed win an election as
they did in
2005 do you buy into any of that I mean
do you think that Israel
has overreacted already to what happened
to them their argument is what is
proportion when you have a terror attack
like that on your people look since my
childhood uh and I am hearing the
stories from Pro Palestine and from
those who are using what so-call the
Palestinian
cause they care the least for the
Palestinian children and their future
you know I I am the legit legitimate
representative of of the Palestinian
children the child Within Me speaks I
don't want somebody coming from London
or somebody coming from the other side
of the world to tell me what is the
struggle of the Palestinian children the
Palestinian children the Palestinian
Society has been hijacked by this
criminals and anybody who takes side
their side is participating in their
crime this is my answer to those people
and for the civilian casualties ET
you know first of all Hamas is using and
it's very clearly it's a fact that Hamas
used civilians as human sheets it's a
fact then it's a fact that Israel called
and warn civilians to evacuate buildings
before they strike them but in the
meantime Hamas put roadblocks to stop
civilians from evacuating to Safe zones
Hamas single misfire killed hundreds of
ref is taking shelter at a hospital and
they blamed Israel what are we talking
about here Israel is a democracy Israel
is accountable Israel is not thirsty for
the Palestinian blood in the meantime
Israel is capable of wiping out Arab
Capitals in seconds why Israel does not
attempt to abuse its power but why when
the Arabs have just a little bit of
power couple of missiles they miss use
power by lunching them at civilians and
kill them in their living rooms we have
a fundamental problem and we need to
stop blaming Israel we invited this upon
our heads and the rest of the world if
they don't know the reality on the
ground it's better than shut up mosab
your passion uh and your anger is very
palpable here and certainly very
different to most of the pro Palestinian
voices I've had and you I sense the
Palestinian plight of its people is very
much in your heart do you still have
contact with with any of your family
this is irrelevant right now I don't
have any contact with my family and I
don't care anymore you know enough
Bloodshed and enough involvement from
people who don't care they just uh
warriors on keyboard you know and
they're just
storming uh world capitals saying free
Palestine free Palestine they don't know
what the hell Palestine is I am
Palestine and I say is enough of Hamas
it's enough of the corrupt leaderships
that they are killing our people
misleading them to hell is enough of
that we don't want Palestinian State I
don't want Palestinian State Palestinian
children need education they need
security they need life this is what
they need they don't need another
corrupt Arab regime is it possible to
get rid of Hamas in the way that Israel
is currently trying to do through uh air
strike bombardments and and it is
planned now an imminent ground invasion
is that the best way to do it is there a
danger of radicalizing a lot more young
Palestinians to the Hamas cause in the
process listen to
this we are going to remove Hamas from
Power remember my words okay and Hamas
did not only bring the wrath of Israel
Over Gaza Hamas brought the wrath of God
we are are going to remove them from
power and we are going to persecute
their leaders and we are going to bring
them bring them to justice and the world
will witness their punishment and
everyone who who take their side today
in this state of confusion thinking that
this is a joke I tell those people that
you're are going to regret taking the
side of Hamas you are going to take the
to regret taking the side of those
criminals who are uh killing uh the
Palestinian people mosab you were born
in rala that's your home do you dream of
going
home one day is that something you still
aspire to do I prefer not to ask to
answer this question I understand mosab
thank you very much indeed for joining
me um it's it's extraordinary to hear
your story and it's uh a remarkable
pitch that you make to the people of
Palestine and it's one that um they will
hear we'll see their reaction but I
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much thank
you